everything that I learned in the Navy is
not built for this game at all my name
is Jonathan doc Farrow I was a corpsman
in the United States Navy serving with
the United States Marine Corps I am Lisa
I was an intelligence specialist I was a
medic
the guy who patched you up if you got
shot I served in Virginia Beach Bahrain
and on the USS bonhomme rashard the last
time that I played battleship
we'll say 25 years ago 1984 was the last
time I played nope 1986 I wanted to win
some because I'm doc you know I was
actually stationed on a ship so I think
I'm gonna kick his ass
right let's do it
you'll never think to eschew be there
somebody's gonna lose this is not
basically how a carrier group would be
by the way and you know this how how
would you do
I was on an amphibious assault ship
already be to direct hit yes D for myth
as I suspected
I'm sorry what was that hits direct it
okay great
sweet I'm chasing after you I'm
adjusting fire you too I'm already gonna
put it in there D too much time solution
okay hate yes I'm sorry II - is it you
sank my battleship you guys miss D buy
it
Miss America going down you're going out
you sank my destroyer
how you feeling dying over here
starting to sweat yeah I sweat all the
time shut up it it I wasted it I know
it's all I know
remember this being so stressful when I
was stressful g8 is he bringing packages
to your show I just said some [ __ ] right
there did not you got a direct hit and I
know where the next one's going baby
saying they Sun Tzu's next you didn't
think my courier you carry it hi son
your patrol boat you didn't see my first
roller destroyer u-boat we didn't have
u-boats all right well we keep you in
1940 the Germans head Oh what happened
what I say some way destroyers good
strategy takes time you're getting
bombed you're on time j9
I went in there with a good game plan of
putting the ships and the pegs we came
out victorious